[Applause]
thank you thank you good morning class
of 2019 Thank You president Tessier
levine for that very generous
introduction I'll do my best to earn it
before I begin I want to recognize
everyone whose hard work made this
celebration possible including the
groundskeepers pushers volunteers and
crew thank you
I am deeply honored and frankly a little
astonished to be invited to join you for
this most meaningful of occasions
graduates this is your day but you
didn't get here alone
family and friends teachers mentors
loved ones and of course your parents
all work together to make you possible
and they share your joy today here on
Father's Day let's give the dads in
particular a round of applause
Stanford is near to my heart not least
because I live just a mile and a half
from here of course if my accident
hasn't given it away for the first part
of my life I had to admire this place
from a distance I went to school on the
other side of the country at Auburn
University in the heart of landlocked
eastern Alabama you may not know this
but I was on the sailing team all four
years
it wasn't easy back then the closest
marina was a three-hour drive for
practice most of the time we had to wait
for a heavy rainstorm to flood the
football field and tying knots is hard
who knew
yet somehow against all odds we managed
to beat Stanford every time we must have
gotten lucky with a win kidding aside I
know the real reason I'm here and I
don't take it lightly Stanford and
Silicon Valley's roots are woven
together we're part of the same
ecosystem it was true when Steve stood
on this stage 14 years ago it's true
today and presumably it'll be true for a
while longer still the past few decades
have lifted us together but today we
gather at a moment that demands some
reflection fueled by caffeine and code
optimism and idealism conviction in AI
and creativity generations of Stanford
graduates and dropouts have used
technology to remake our society but I
think you would agree that lately the
results haven't been neat or
straightforward in just the four years
that you've been here at the farm things
feel like they've taken a sharp turn
crisis has tempered optimism
consequences had challenged idealism and
reality has shaken blind faith and yet
we are still drawn here for good reason
bit dreams live here as do the genius
and passion to make them real in an age
of cynicism this place still believes
that the human capacity to solve
problems is boundless
but so it seems is our potential to
create them that's what I'm interested
in talking about today because if I've
learned one thing it's the technology
doesn't change who we are it magnifies
who we are the good and the bad our
problems in technology in politics
wherever our human problems from the
Garden of Eden to today it's our
humanity that got us into this mess and
it's our humanity that's going to have
to get us out first things first
here's a plain fact Silicon Valley is
responsible for some of the most
revolutionary inventions in modern
history from the first oscillator built
in a Hewlett Packard garage to the
iPhones that I know you're holding in
your hands social media shareable video
snaps and stories that connect half the
people on earth they all trace their
roots to Stanford's backyard but lately
it seems this industry is becoming
better known for a less noble innovation
the belief that you can claim credit
without accepting responsibility we see
it every day now with every data breach
every privacy violation every blind I
turn to hate speech fake news poisoning
our national conversation the false
miracles in exchange for a single drop
of your blood to many seem to think that
good intentions excuse away harmful
outcomes but whether you like it or not
what you build and what you create
define who you are it feels a bit crazy
that anyone should have to say this but
if you've built a chaos Factory you
can't dodge responsibility for the chaos
taking responsibility means having the
courage to think things through and
there are few areas where this is more
important than privacy if we accept as
normal and unavoidable that everything
in our lives can be aggregated sold or
even leaked in the event of a hack then
we lose so much more than data we lose
the freedom to be human think about
what's at stake everything you write
everything you say every topic of
curiosity every stray thought every
impulsive purchase every moment of
frustration or weakness every gripe or
complaint every secret shared in
confidence in a world without digital
privacy even if you have done nothing
wrong other than think differently you
begin to censor yourself not entirely at
first just a little bit by bit to risk
less to hope less to imagine less to
dare less to create less to try less to
talk less to think less the chilling
effect of digital surveillance is
profound and it touches everything what
a small unimaginative world we would end
up with not entirely at first just a
little bit by bit
ironically it's the kind of environment
that would have stopped Silicon Valley
before it ever gotten started we deserve
better you deserve better if we believe
that freedom means an environment where
great ideas can take root where they can
grow and be nurtured without fear of
irrational restrictions or burdens then
it's our duty to change course
because your generation ought to have
the same freedom to shape the future as
the generation that came before
graduates at the very least learn from
these mistakes if you want to take
credit first learn to take
responsibility
[Applause]
now a lot of you
the vast majority won't find yourselves
in tech at all
that's as it should be we need your
minds at work far and wide because our
challenges are great and they can't be
solved by any single industry no matter
where you go no matter what you do I
know you will be ambitious you wouldn't
be here today if you aren't match that
ambition with humility a humility of
purpose that doesn't mean being tamer
being smaller being less in what you do
it's the opposite it's about serving
something greater the author Madeleine
L'Engle Road humility is throwing
oneself away in complete concentration
on something or someone else in other
words whatever you do with your life be
a builder you don't have to start from
scratch to build something monumental
and conversely the best founders the
ones whose creations last and whose
reputations grow rather than shrink with
passing time they spend most of their
time building piece by piece builders
are comfortable in the belief that their
life's work will one day be bigger than
them bigger than any one person they're
mindful that its effects will span
generations that's not an accident in a
way it's the whole point in a few days
we will mark the 50th anniversary of the
riots at Stonewall when the patrons of
the Stonewall Inn showed up that night
people of all races gay and transgender
young and old they had no idea what
history had in store for them
it would have seemed foolish to dream it
when the door was busted open by police
it was not the knock of opportunity or
the call of Destiny it was just another
instance of the world telling them that
they ought to feel worthless for being
different but the group gathered there
felt something strengthened in them a
conviction that they deserved something
better than the shadows and better than
Oblivion and it if it wasn't going to be
given then they were going to have to
build it themselves
I was eight years old and a thousand
miles away when stonewall happened there
were no news alerts no way for photos to
go viral no mechanism for a kid on the
Gulf Coast to hear these unlikely heroes
tell their stories Greenwich Village may
as well have been a different planet
though I can tell you that the slurs and
hatreds were the same
what I would not know for a long time
was what I owed to a group of people I
never knew in a place I'd never been yet
I will never stop being grateful for
what they had the courage to build
graduates being a builder is about
believing that you cannot possibly be
the greatest cause on this earth because
you aren't built to last it's about
making peace with the fact that you
won't be here for the end of the story
that brings me to my last bit of advice
14 years ago Steve stood on this stage
and told your predecessors your time is
limited so don't waste it living someone
else's life here's my corollary your
mentors may leave you prepared but they
can't leave you ready when Steve got
sick I had hardwired my thinking to the
belief that he would get better I not
only thought he would hold on I was
convinced down to my core that he'd
still be guiding Apple long after I
myself was gone then one day he called
me over to his house and told me that it
wasn't going to be that way
even then I was convinced he would stay
on as chairman that he would step back
from the day-to-day but always be there
as a sounding board
but there was no reason to believe that
I never should have thought it the facts
were all there and when he was gone
truly gone I learned the real visceral
difference between preparation and
readiness it was the loneliest I've ever
felt in my life
by an order of magnitude it was one of
those moments where you can be
surrounded by people yet you don't
really see hear or feel them but I could
sense their expectations when the dust
settled all I knew was that I was going
to have to be the best version of myself
that I could be I knew that if you got
out of bed every morning and set your
watch by what other people expect or
demand you to drive you crazy so what
was true then it's true now don't waste
your time living someone else's life
don't try to emulate the people who came
before you to the exclusion of
everything else contorting into a shape
that doesn't fit it takes too much
mental effort effort that should be
dedicated to creating and building
you'll waste precious time trying to
rewire your every thought and in the
meantime you won't be fooling anybody
graduates the fact is when your time
columns and it will you'll never be
ready
but you're not supposed to be find the
hope in the unexpected find the courage
in the challenge find your vision on the
solitary road don't get distracted there
are too many people who won't credit
without responsibilities too many who
show up for the ribbon-cutting without
building anything worth a damn be
different leave something worthy and
always remember that you can't take it
with you you're going to have to pass it
on thank you very much and
congratulations to the class of 2019
[Applause]
[Music]